jamal
100% debbouze
le spectacle enregistré au zénith de
paris
dvd 2 les bonus alors jamel debbouze
bruxelles 30 et 31 décembre au zénith de
paris
voilà si on veut terminer l'année comme
il faut je crois que c'est une bonne
idée alors dans le bonus on vous voit
chercher des vannes avec kader aoun et
moi je vous ai vu à l'époque je me
souviens de votre flip avant l'avant la
tournée parce que c'était le deuxième
spectacle c'est pas évident le premier
avait été un énorme succès et il fallait
transformer l'essai ce n'était pas gagné
d'avancé
non mais d'ailleurs si jamais gagné
d'avancé mais c'est vrai que le deuxième
c'est toujours un peu difficile à
aborder que le premier le premier on y
va avec une certaine fébrilité
et puis le deuxième c'est celle là il
faut plus ou moins confirmée même si
c'est pas la pression du public qui
comptait pour moi à ce moment là c'est
vraiment là près mal à la main elles
sont je me suis mis moi pour moi un
allez choisir choisissent les les les
bons mots et que je me trompe pas sur ce
que j'avais envie de raconter j'avais
envie de raconter tellement de choses
que ça allait dans tous les sens et
kader m'a beaucoup aidé pour ça
d'ailleurs si tu m'écoutes l'algérienne
je te kiffe
alors ce qui est bien avec vous c'est
que votre énorme succès nous est pas
monté à la tête veut pas mettez les
plombs ça c'est faux non pas du tout
venant si j'ai la grosse tête mais ça ça
se voit pas d'image et puis en plus
malgré le succès vous avez pas fermer
votre gueule
vous n'êtes pas devenu trop
politiquement correct il ya une phrase
comme ce avant le spectacle qu'ils ont
dit l'ansés l'ascenseur social il est
bloqué au sous sol il sent la pisse
non mais mais mais mais bizarrement ça
c'est même ça s'est même renforcé ma
conscience politique
cc c'est même le plus plus plus ma plume
avis s'adoucit je dirais plus je suis
détendu et plus je me rends compte qu
effectivement quand je vivais à trappes
j'ai accepté des choses que j'ai
j'accepterai plus jamais aujourd'hui tu
vois le fait d'arrêter habite
aujourd'hui à saint germain des primes
après m'a fait prendre conscience de
boules beaucoup de choses c'est sûr
germain des prés c'est mieux beau gentil
dans le meilleur des cas le silence qui
est épouvantable la nuit quand les chats
possible impossible à dormir le soir
obligé de les applaudir c'est pas fini
si long
vous n'avez pas pris la grosse tête vous
n'avez pas renier vos origines mais vous
n'êtes pas vendu non plus parce que vous
avez refusé par exemple de faire le
prochain film de francis veber comme un
des plus grands réalisateurs français
parce que voilà c'était pas votre cas
vous n'avez pas envie de le faire
j'adore francis hébert j'adorerais mais
beaucoup de ces fines l'emmerdeur la
chèvre les compères j'en passe et des
meilleurs mais mais c'est vrai que là je
m'attendais pas à mieux mais mais mais
mais à différents c'est sûr que c'est
sûr que camper le personnage de françois
pignon ça implique enfin je veux dire
par là que je je je m'attendais à autre
chose en fait mais mais j'aspire à
travailler avec lui en s'éclatant sais
c'est pas c'est pas perdu mais sur ce
coup là non on a dit que le film s'est
pas fait parce que vous demandiez 3
millions 1,5 euro 4,4 millions de jeux
j'étais je lisais le scénario on avait
on n'a rien négocié du tout on a vingt
jours rien négocier aujourd'hui c'est
d'abord artistiquement que ça se passe
si si si si le personnage le scénario ne
nous convient pas il hors de question de
négocier quoi que ce soit mais si vous
convient vous accepté de le faire pour
moins cher puisque vous faites le film
de rachid bouchareb indigènes pour 300
euros par jour là vous êtes plus
l'artiste le mieux payé de france d'être
le moins bien payé la société et
arcangues ira partout on commence par le
dire ce soir à la télé alors indigènes
c'est l'histoire d'un bataillon de
tirailleurs sénégalais venus libérer la
france à la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale on les voit de l'italie aux
vosges et à la sortie l'on paie le droit
de défiler sur les champs elysées et
parce qu'ils étaient arabes ou noirs
oui enfin je je je suppose que c'est que
c'est à cause de ça mais mais mais ils
nous ont sorti plein de prétexte à
l'époque mais c'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui
les mieux lotis d'entre eux ils sont
dans des foyers sonacotra a collectionné
paquet pathé et s'il admissibles vu les
sacrifices qu'ils ont faits pour nous
aujourd'hui je suis là devant vous à
répondre à ces questions débiles c'est
parce que rigole mais parce que se sont
sacrifiés parce que parce
qu'effectivement enfin j'ai pas envie
d'oublier leurs sacrifices et à travers
ce film j'ai envie de pouvoir raconter à
mes petits frères à tous ceux qui
veulent bien l'entendre qu'on est con et
légitime ici qu'on est français
moi j'ai grandi ici j'ai vécu ici je
suis un musicien comme il n'ya pas
d'intégration n'a pas l'intégration pour
toi mais moi le mot intégration
n'existait pas je te dis c'est serment
qui a été inventé par kofi yamgnane à
l'époque justifié ce travers non mais
c'est vrai je ne considère pas qu'il
faut pas qu'il ne faut pas rentrer dans
ce jeu là on est on n'a pas à se
justifier et expliquer pourquoi on est
on est légitime ici on est venu ici un
point c'est tout voilà
vous remercie
c'est moi
meyer
quelqu'un l'a évidemment
alors c'est jean-marc un croque dans ses
émissions il ya de plus en plus de jeux
de jolis 6 1
bonjour madame
j'aime plus que vous faites depuis le
début de cette émission si on regarde a
fait un bisou c'est pas faux elle pas
que la guerre fait un gros plan sur un
char merci par quatre le guen donc alors
indigènes donc c'est un film avec samy
naceri roschdy zem sami bouajila et
notre ami jamel debbouze tournage début
janvier sortie dans un monde qu'on en
parle c'est pas une comédie on n'est pas
dans la rigolade
moi mon arrière grand père et écrire
ailleurs et est en plus en plus de pas
avoir le droit de défiler sur les champs
le deuxième bureau a fait plein de
choses un peu bizarre comme interdire
les correspondances qui a empêché un peu
les couples mixtes de se former un
il arrive à marseille les villes et les
villages les meuf elle était comme des
folles peu importe uniforme elle sauté
dans leurs bras et avant six mois six
mois et donc s'amouracher comme ils
pouvaient sauf que c'était pas c'était
pas bien vu de 20 du point de vue de
monsieur de gaulle puis à son âme
alors toujours plusieurs au niveau du
cinéma faisait là fils de she hate me
c'est l'histoire d'un cadre sup qui perd
son emploi et qui devient étalon pour la
communauté lesbienne de new york cherche
et alain paulin vente est vraiment même
temps ce périple il a ses torts vieux
pour ça alors vous qui jouez le pont
sierre jeu français d'un hôtel donc
dragueur yes it's not about
j'avais envie de parler anglais parce
que bon tout le monde ne comprend pas je
vais sur le tournage parce que ce pays
qu ils parlent pas français ce fut parle
pas anglais comment vas tu parle un peu
toi
au départ il va proposer le premier rôle
son film va poser la question fatidique
il m'a dit mister kahn laisse j'ai
répondu faites en bois là
acrobates à peu près comme ça alors
c'est en vous rendant djamel sur le
tournage de ce film que vous êtes arrivé
vous arabe à l'aéroport avec un
passeport français
donc vous en regardez quand même temps
cinq heures sa mère sur soi même cinq
modes phoque s'amusait à les sauver
c'était un peu un peu bizarre mais bon
qu'est ce que ça va ils sont énervés ils
ont peur j'en suis lavé tu l'avais dit
si je me souviens on s'était vus fin
septembre 2001 et tu avais dit ça va
être dur pour les arabes
même en france quoi ouais mais c'est ça
oui ça va être dur oui c'est de plus en
plus dur on sait bien c'est moi moi moi
franchement je
j'espère de tout mon coeur qu'on va vers
une issue mais là on vient de resigner
pour 4 piges je crois ce qui va pas
aller dans l'autre sens évident mais
mais j'ai confiance
j'ai confiance en l'avenir j'ai
confiance en mon petit frère j'ai
confiance en plein de choses que je vois
il ya de plus en plus de robots eux qui
font des choses que ce soit hedi slimane
qu'un arabe immédiat des dames qui est à
ramos leaf le fâcheux dire yahia g
l'obscurantisme
on sait on sait ce que c'est c'est cdc
d'abord je pense des gens frustrés qui
est qui souffrent fondamentalement je
pense que tant qu on les combattra on
n'arrivera à rien il faut les convaincre
et les etats unis ils n'ont pas compris
qu'il fallait convaincre pages en tout
cas je pense que george bush n'a pas
compris ça non donc tant qu'on n'ira pas
dans ce sens là c'est la merde
alors
le film de spike lui est sorti le 17
novembre
je viens d'apprendre ça ne s'était pas
pourquoi mais si on me dit rien moi
c'est la dernière roue du carrosse plus
tarder à saran et que personne ne me dit
rien je savais pas merde c'est un succès
énorme entre le mode de foccart
alors vous on vous a pas vu au cinéma
depuis depuis astérix à es22 par dieu
que la ville ont fait dix films parce
qu'ils avaient besoin d'acheter des
séries je suppose ouais je sais pas non
chacun de chacun bois ça doit être dur
comme on doit vous proposer toutes les
comédies qui passe j'imagine non non
mais c'est pas dur ccc même gratifiant
c'est dur de dire non quand même non moi
j'essaie vraiment ce que j'ai ce que je
vais faire je vais m'amuser toute ma vie
ils ont la chance de faire ce métier
aujourd'hui comme on dit chez moi j'ai
le choix et c'est le plus grand des news
pour vous j'espère le garder le plus
longtemps possible
si je me retrouve dans des films moyens
avec des personnages difficile à
défendre et si je vais à reculons je
vais me décevoir je vais décevoir donc
j'ai pas envie d'autres banques d'être
dans cette position je préfère monter
sur celle qui fait c'est vraiment ses
promesses quand même le plus au monde et
et je me suis amusé comme un fou à
écrire ce spectacle met dans tous ses
films
vous avez refusé y en a un que vous
regrettez de ne pas avoir fait quand
même ouais j'ai déconné georges accepter
une diana jones quand on m'a proposé à
l'époque
le sens des mots doux
souhaite moscou pour ceux qui
connaissent